what's up you guys
yeah it's Monday another one of our side
tracks yeah boring ass Monday yeah we
really haven't been doing it site well
that's the thing it's like I don't
really war woke up today did you well I
don't feel like a well here's what ends
up happening it's like I usually wake up
between 3 and 4 o'clock in the morning
because I have to pay and then you gotta
pee
yeah well no I'm just saying most people
to get up and pee in the middle of it
especially you get older but then the
problem is it's like so I get back in
bed get all comfy and then Pookie has
heard me awake so she's like oh you're
awake Hey and then like so a second
after I get in bed they're a little
pause so on the way she's like run it up
your legs and she wakes me up because
she the kids you won't do anything you
know because you're not getting up so
then she wakes me up
you have to aren't you does it yeah I
guess I'm up and trying to go back to
sleep I put my headphones back on
because it's hard for me to fall back
asleep in silence I got to have
something distracting me see I'm the
opposite I'm like I don't like like
having a bunch of noise and listen you
know unless I'm really really sleepy and
then sometimes like I'll fall asleep
during a movie or something but other
than that I don't really like a lot of
noise because it keeps like waking me
back up hard for me to fall asleep in
total silence cuz I'll just start
thinking and I'll just hear my damn and
her thoughts going well I do that too
but to me yeah but yeah that's the thing
and so so Pookie is like she doesn't
mean it it's like she just thinks while
you're awake so it's Pookie playtime and
so she'll come up and she just you know
and she's she's little but she's what
like 10 pounds or something like that
now so you can feel it when she jumps on
the edge of the road and she jumps on
your legs and like runs up your entire
body like I just stops on your stomach
and then like sits on your chest like
right and then sticks her face right in
your face yeah then she's like hey it
was just big black darkness like staring
at you you awake or your eyes open what
are we doing and then she just kind of
lays or she'll lay like across you this
way you know what I mean would you think
is very funny with like she'll stand up
like with her a little
backbeat yeah and then like put her
front P then she just lays there purrs
and let you better this apocalypse is
boring well everybody's been it's
[ __ ] boring I even I a not the
exciting apocalypse that I was talking
promise okay
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] I've been
robbed
alright I've been looking I've been
looking at the dam at the death toll in
our county and still only one person has
died in the past two weeks for this [ __ ]
and and and it's not it's not growing as
quickly as a large county is like well
last I checked and I think that was a
day or two ago Orange County which is
where downtown Orlando is they've had
like four times yet but out here in
Seminole some misses were a little more
rural yeah it went population in the
past in the past two weeks it went from
thirty I think twenty five or thirty
people in the hospital to about forty
people in the hospital yeah it's not and
and it and the death toll was zero for a
long time and then one popped in I think
about a week ago
week and a half ago and then no more and
there's only like total infected I think
there's only like a hundred and not even
200 it's like 190 well like I said yeah
I knocked it was like a hundred and
forty-eight or something yeah and it
only went up by 50 people or 60 people
in a week so it's not growing that fast
yeah well like I said it's because a lot
of Seminole I mean it's have kind of
built up or we are over it yeah most of
it suburbs and people are kind of spread
out and most people are you know at home
asleep yeah are staying home although
like I said you know when you go to the
grocery store and stuff like that
there's still people yeah but they do
seem to be taking precautions and [ __ ]
like that so it doesn't really seem to
be spreading like I said it's it seems
like you know obviously the the chances
of you getting is gonna be higher like
the more people are around just because
that's what was looking at Miami dad kid
Miami dad dodd county weed Dade Dade
yeah Miami that's a which is the most
populated county and it still doesn't
look that bad well like I said nowhere
near it's gonna depend on where you are
nowhere near New York City if people are
like taking Prakash
not going out when they don't have to
yeah it's almost all of its happening up
in New York City it looks like if you're
looking at the numbers because you know
Miami is looking pretty good I think 20
people have died yeah you know no man I
don't know what the average age is
probably eighties 70s or 80s
yeah I'm not real sure they do have like
kind of an aging population down there
but yeah that's not all yeah that so you
know we have friends down there so I was
expecting some [ __ ] out of the Omega man
wait you thought you were just gonna be
able to run around around just [ __ ]
say I have CEO brand-new Mustangs and
nobody cared [ __ ] catch an heir and
[ __ ] with the [ __ ] muscle cars and
shooting out the window and stuff you
know come on well where's my exciting
apocalypse I did see somebody post I
don't remember who it was but somebody
posted on Instagram the other day like a
[ __ ] like one of those signs it was
like out in front of a bar or a
restaurant or something with it and they
said the same thing they said you know
where's this is a boring apocalypse I
wanted some B yeah yeah I'm like dude
you really though I mean you know what I
mean it's mostly sleeping all day and
listening to the kids play in the
backyard yeah cuz all the dogs barking
yeah cuz our neighborhoods like they
have like a little girl and a dog and so
there's a little girl screams and like
the dog barks and that's for them it's
just this is having a good time
well yeah they're like well I mean they
do but it's like they're doing all
homeschooling they're doing all class
like so that's the thing I was thinking
the other day I was like it's really got
to suck for people I mean you know it
sucks for everybody obviously for
different reasons but it's really gonna
suck for people that have like several
kids because you not only not only your
kids not only are you trying to work at
home but all your kids are home yeah and
they have to do like online classes and
[ __ ] too so you have to like pretend to
be yeah the teacher and like make sure
they're doing what they're supposed to
be doing and you're supposed to be doing
what you're supposed to be doing and
[ __ ] like that and it's like everybody's
living on top of each other it's like
yeah I can see some people like [ __ ]
killing each other after a while Jenny
got mad at me this morning as I made
that biscuits and gravy I wasn't mad I
was just
get me fat yeah okay so the thing is I
don't like that be good put on the show
Jenny getting mad at me [ __ ] about
biscuits and gravy
I made biscuits gravy one too many times
I got a lot of it extra I got a lot of
leftover we've made it like several
times like in there so I'm just kind of
like get into it well that's the thing
is like this business this quick the
best quick new Bisquick it all worked
out yeah I got new worked out new the
last it was it was 2014 yes I was like
six years like I can't believe that that
[ __ ] box of Bisquick was in there
that that amount of time I can't believe
that either
I can't how could that can't believe it
that it wasn't in the back what I can't
believe that that bacon that baking
powder not baking soda but that baking
powder was from 2005 well that I believe
I can baby there's that old it did it
felt like ice inside that like when you
lived over the place yeah cuz we've
lived here what nine years almost nine
yeah I can't believe it that I had it
that I had a can of something that long
and it didn't dawn on me that that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] old you know which thing is
I have more than one can of that that
was one yep getting pushed to the back
to the back yeah that's what it's not
like we've just been using that up like
that it's not something I have multiple
ones yeah it's like sometimes I'll get
lost in some people yeah see how I go
into the back and I'm like oh I still
got some and then realized that that was
the [ __ ] that I was just kept getting
pushed to the back well in all of our
another thing too is that all of our
stuff isn't in the same place it's like
they have one little we have one cabinet
that has like all the spices and stuff
and I used lots of Bisquick and bought
lots of Bisquick say that one thing a
Bisquick must have just been one that
kept getting pushed to the to the back
yeah it had to been but yeah so we have
the one that has like old spices and
then there's another one that has like
baking stuff like cornstarch and brown
sugar brown sugar and then we have like
a like a pantry like a real pantry that
has you know canned goods and
oatmeal and [ __ ] like that in there yeah
rice and whatnot so it's so it's easy to
first stuff to get like push behind and
you don't see it and then like next time
you're the story like oh I think we're
out of this and then you get another one
and then you just use that and you
forget that you had like one that wasn't
even open in there
you said oatmeal and I thought that man
I bought some that oatmeal milk and I've
never drank it before yeah you should
try it out milk I'm sorry I have to tell
you that I'm like so glad that they have
like all these other kind of I'm not
like lactose intolerant or anything like
that but for a long time like I guess
because my cholesterol was really high
puts a lot of weight on him because well
yeah because I used to love [ __ ]
whole milk like when I was growing up
and I would just drink like huge glasses
of it like ice and everything and I was
like I think that was one of the main
contributors like to all the weight gain
that I had like in my teenage years and
stuff was all this melon all that milk
yeah so because when I switched for a
while like all you could get was like
soy milk which is okay but it's it
doesn't really taste all that good you
have to like you can't I don't really
like it like yeah like almond milk like
you know I think there's lady mail the
cashew milk I haven't tried the oatmeal
we he bought some oatmeal
milk it yeah they were right they store
because I bought you know they're they
were out of it so not don't had one of
that one of those left and I saw I saw
oatmeal sitting there and it was only 10
cents more so I got a couple of those
yeah
it looked good from the photograph of it
you know it's the package I said man
that ought to be good too I just think
it let's think of down low well then the
graphic designer succeed as and and the
photographer yeah here's a picture that
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] late good [ __ ] no
gone yeah it'd be good we'll see yeah I
mean you know I I don't really use a lot
of milk anymore usually mostly you you
make like shakes with it I got that I
got that South American powdered milk
neat oh yeah and if I need milk to cook
with I just use that I can make cream
with that too yeah if you guys don't
know that don't don't know anything
about powdered milk you can go to
Walmart in the South American section
they have these big yellow cans of
powdered milk and it's good they have
two different ones once some of them
that's rated for
and other ones just to make regular milk
we used to drink that in Brazil because
getting fresh milk sometimes was hard
you know said it actually it wasn't
fresh when you did back when I was there
when you did get milk it came in a damn
plastic bag and it was frozen when you
bought it
yes and you had to let it thaw because
at that time Brazil didn't have a good
network of [ __ ] delivering fresh milk
you know so a lot of houses for cooking
purposes used powdered milk and you made
your milk up and that's how you'll be
used in your recipe that's what I use
mostly use it for but actually if you if
you have it iced down and put some ice
in it make it a little bit thick it's
good remember I drank so I made a little
bit of extra that one time by accident
just drank it yeah you just try could I
just tell ya I was like yeah it's pretty
damn good you know yeah be good for
survival you know imma put that in there
your MRE years well it's shelf-stable
shell stabling that's why they were
using it in Brazil in South America
because you know you know they don't
have enough room in those little
frigerator sometimes yeah and then some
people don't have any refrigeration you
know real poor people don't have it so
they're just you know everything had to
be shelf stable yeah for a while I was
you know like a long time ago for a
while I was using a Parmalat which which
is liquid milk but you can like keep it
on the shelf I was looking for some
apocalypse eggs you know okay yeah which
is that's damn powdered eggs yeah and I
couldn't find him I guess yeah those are
kind of hard to find there's it's easy
to find like egg substitutes but they're
usually refrigerated yeah cuz I used to
get like those ones either hot yeah I
wanted some kind of shelf stable
powdered eggs that I could make sure
they have that somewhere I just I had it
before you know and it's terrible
usually they're kind of terrible but you
might but I only had them plain and kind
of like paramilitary type situations you
know I mean they can you be good enough
sriracha on that [ __ ] yeah I was figured
because my baby make an omelet figure
you might go to make an omelet out of it
put a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch stuff in it
might be alright but I wanted experiment
with it yeah trying to wade a way to
have shelf-stable eggs yeah but yes what
I was saying this what you were saying
about me being a mad at you instantly it
wasn't necessarily mad at you it's just
that I get you know we got up really
early because like I said Pookie woke us
up and then like I just got up went
ahead and got up at 7:00 cuz I went out
for a walk right and then he got back
and he was like cleaning up the kitchen
and making coffee and [ __ ] and then I
was just kind of like taking a shower
and putting on my face and everything
and then he just brings people with like
[ __ ] with the biscuits and pork gravy
and like eggs and everything and I was
kind of like man that's a lot of way you
have to eat it all yes early in the
morning I couldn't you didn't have to
eat it I couldn't I mean I don't
normally I don't eat breakfast most of
the time and if I do it'll only be like
I'll have like a little a packet of
oatmeal or like a little cup of yogurt
or something or a boy a hard-boiled egg
it's like I can't I love breakfast food
but I can't do big breakfast right
anymore and I and I can't reel and I
especially can't do it that early in the
morning like my stomach will be like no
yeah and it's just oh so much food and
it's like I'm really really trying to
her not to wake we're almost done with
the fat we're almost done with the
kingdom yeah oh we got two more episodes
right yeah it's a good series it's
really good I know it's like we're gonna
watch that tonight I think it's the
Korean version of The Walking Dead
you just watch that [ __ ] subtitled and
it's taking place like in the 1500s in
the Korean Middle Ages
I guess you could say and zombie
outbreak yeah and it's all done with
kind of within the confines of 1500s
Korean mentality you have made their
explanation of what it is and I like
that I like the way they did that plus I
like that they're trying to uphold their
damn cultural connotations less I like
that there's like it's not just Dom B's
there's like also all this like really
intricate like palace intrigue yeah and
all this other kind of like everyone's
backstabbing and like it's better than
everything
it's basically zombie basically a
samurai flick but with zombie but with
zombies in it yeah even though the
Koreans didn't have samurai they had
just Knights and war
and soldiers yes similar type similar to
a Japanese samurai right but it's like I
have to say I don't know I'm imagining
that probably the gore is probably a
combination of practical and CGI like
they don't Walking Dead but it looks
really good yeah I mean it looks like a
really high budget series I don't know
what the budget is on it look yeah it's
as high as The Walking Dead yeah I
really it's probably higher than the
first couple seasons it's a lot more
cinematic than the Walking Dead is like
it's just in the in in terms of scope
yeah they were showing you know the the
Korean countryside you know the rice
paddies in the mountains and boys just
taking me back to when I was there you
know it's like like having flashbacks I
was going oh yeah I remember that you
know I remember what you know just the
setting is perfect
ya know that's the way it looked and
they're not showing sets that's the real
thing man those are real Korean castles
now I don't know if they were made for
other movies but that's I don't know if
that's some tourist stuff that they made
but that looks you know what I mean that
you can tell that that's not fake those
are real buildings they're running
around yeah all right the Japanese have
that kind of stuff too
you know they're like cultural centers
now you know I would like to go I would
like to go to Korea yeah what does take
you there one of these days it's far
when when well yeah that's the only
thing that bothers me about it is like
being on a plane for that long cuz man I
really hate flying and and honestly
though I think the longest plate I've
ever been on was like nine hours or nine
and a half hours and even that I was
like climbing up two [ __ ] sides at
the airplane yeah give me the [ __ ] off
this bang you know what I mean yeah it's
weird because I didn't fly until I was
in my 20s and then the first like the
first few times I flew it didn't bother
me at all like I thought it would bother
me and then it didn't but then I was on
this really really really bad flight
where I mean it was one of those ones
where the turbulence was so bad you
could feel the plane like dropping
several hundred feet in the air
you know the stewardess all the
stewardesses are kind of freaking out
and like people were barfing in to their
hats and stuff like that and I was just
kind of like oh my god
again it was like horrifying and it and
it was only like an hour and a half into
like a nine or ten power gird nine hour
flight and so like for the rest of the
flight I was just saying cuz I knew I
couldn't get off you couldn't land it's
like flying over the Atlantic [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
I do not like it but I still I've you
know I do want to get a career though so
but we have to do it like in bits just
so I wouldn't like so it wouldn't get
meant we could have to change planes
well yeah it's like cuz I you know I can
handle being alive from here directly to
there
no you have - yeah yeah not one plane -
yeah you have to sadly I'm just saying
it's like it'd be good you know being on
a plane like for more than a couple of
hours I start getting really really
antsy I gotta go over the Pacific though
I know that's that scares me I see it
you know it's easy I well I would rather
you know what I mean it's let it fly I
would rather fly over land I can't sleep
on a plane um I would rather fly over
land because then at least if something
goes wrong maybe they can like find some
place to land it's like you're in the
ocean you're kind of [ __ ] yeah and you
know knowing my luck if I'm on a plane
that's going up for the [ __ ] ocean
and like I've survived the crash and
then a [ __ ] shark eats me yes that's
just what would happen you know what I
mean anything else that you have you had
to bring down Oh somebody on YouTube
recommended a 2011 movie called the
collar and from the description
that sounds pretty [ __ ] awesome I'm
gonna have to like find that I don't
know where it's at or if it's on to be
or I hadn't either but it's like the way
described it sounded like really really
cool and I was like so I definitely have
to check that it sounded almost like one
of those like really good like 70s
made-for-tv horror movies that I love so
much like [ __ ] like when Michael calls
or the strange possession or mrs. Oliver
or something like that or was that one
there was one called yeah there was one
called someone's watching me and John
Carpenter directed that I need to
[ __ ] see that and there was one
called something evil that was like a
weird like pagan haunted house thing and
I think Steven Spielberg did that one
it's just not as famous as dual but it
was really good pretty do that for TV I
think yeah it was for TV that's what I
was saying but yeah so I'm gonna um I
will definitely try and find that and
[ __ ] maybe we could do retrospective on
it one of these days all right but yeah
so uh have the have a good rest of your
Monday and you know stay safe and
healthy out there as always and we'll
talk to you again tomorrow